[Music]
on today's show we're going to be
talking about whether we should leave
a sinking toxic company we're going to
be talking to a young man whose dad
disrespected his wife in his own home
and what he should do about it and we're
going to be talking about connecting
with new sister-in-laws we got a lot
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what is up i'm john and this is the
dr john deloney show
where we're talking about your life your
relationships your friends
your kids we're gonna be talking about
how to re-examine reimagine your life
paint a new picture
put people in your heart put other
people outside of your heart draw your
boundaries
and then go live a well and whole
life we're going to talk about love
we're going to talk about loss we're
going to talk about family issues
holidays elections relationships we
might even talk about what happens when
you walk into the studio and you're
wearing a really cool t-shirt
and your producer looks at you and goes
oh that's that's what we're wearing
today
huh um no that's not what we're wearing
today
and then i have to put this shirt over
it but it does have button snaps but
whatever dude we're going to talk about
all of it so whatever's going on in your
heart in your home or your head
if you've got a boss that just can't let
your cool clothes go
all of it give me a call at
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844 six nine
three
three two nine one or you can email me
at ask
john ramseysolutions.com that's ask john
ramseysolutions.com people are emailing
calling from all over the world
it's incredible it's awesome i love it
you can follow me at youtube at youtube
john delony that's channel has just lost
its mind
you can subscribe to podcast wherever
you get podcast
leave great reviews if you have negative
reviews send them
to james child or kelly daniel to their
personal email and they will delete them
as they get them so let's first go to
michael in minneapolis in minneapolis
minneapolis right michael i'm going to
be able to pronounce the name of your
state sometime
minneapolis it's it's not even that it's
minnesota the city is minnie and apple
yeah it's minneapolis minneapolis
minneapolis perfect
that's right okay so we're having my
call john minneapolis
minnesota michael my brother how are we
doing did you know i used to teach
geography
to high school kids which would probably
tell you all you need to know about the
state of american education minneapolis
minnesota
michael what's up hi john
uh you can hear me right yes i can hear
you great go for it
perfect uh thanks for taking my call so
i guess my question
is whether i should stay at my company
or not
so some background i currently work for
a fortune 500 company that has really
struggled in the past five to ten years
okay my organization recently announced
that my business unit
which is really declining is kind of
being dissolved from the organization
and will be moved to a new entity okay
uh which is yet to be
determined um what does over the past
for those of us like myself who don't
work in a fortune 500
when you say things like it's going to
be moved to a new entity
that sounds like corporate speak that
reminds me of the movie office space
what does that actually mean you're
going to be dissolved and moved to a new
entity
yeah so it won't be part of the existing
organization it'll have a new name
um it and we're kind of learning what it
means too right now but it
has a lot of things up in flux so it
sounds like a corporate mumbo jumbo for
we don't know
and we're gonna put some big words on it
because you don't know
and we don't want you to jump ship on us
but we don't really
we're just getting rid of this because
it's losing money right okay so
thank you for that so continue
perfect yeah so you're spot on um but my
work unit
uh over the past couple of years um will
be like
directly responsible for you know making
this transition happen so it'll be extra
strenuous on us
um but over the past couple of years
it's been pretty toxic environment
extremely stressful and it's only going
to get more
um toxic with all the the moves that are
going on here as well
and so on top of all of this i recently
finished
my mba with this company so i have a
two-year retention with them on my
and then i have to pay it back if i
would leave so that's that's kind of
adding to my you know stress and you
know
inks as well so i'm trying to understand
whether it makes sense to
you know go over to a new company um
you know outside of this completely and
and just make a
a clean you know break with the company
or
if you know it makes sense to really
stay with them
outside of that so there is corporate
stress there is realignment stress
there is this idea that you're trapped
and that lays on all of us right you
were literally
trapped you signed a piece of paper that
said they're going to invest in you
financially
and probably with some time off but in
return you're going to give them two
years
and now it feels like you're on a boat
with holes in it that's sinking
and you chained yourself to it right
with that mba
and you're feeling every alarm you have
is going off right
so i want to i want to back out of the
the
toxicity what i would call the the
you've got
polluted air right now right there's
just so much uncertainty and
they're using words that don't mean
anything that makes everybody
more confused and more anxious than
if they would just be honest with you
but what is it actually doing
in your home and in your day-to-day work
life
is the job itself are you you know
stapling tps reports are you running
your
your your data whatever it is you do on
a day-to-day basis
if you strip the toxicity away and you
strip the the water cooler gossip and
oh my gosh can you believe so and so and
i heard they're moving all the i heards
and i can't believe
you get rid of all that nonsense all
that crap how's the day-to-day life of
the job
yeah so i'm actually in management um so
it's it's even more
stressful because of that because all of
my employees are kind of going with that
and i have to be
you know the person that is stabilizing
the ship all the time
okay um but you know over the past
couple years it's been
you know you start an hour earlier every
day you work an hour later and it just
keeps
you know infringing more on my life
my family um and we're we're looking to
you know grow our family here pretty
shortly so
it's kind of infringing more and more on
you know any balance i did have before
are those expectations that you're
putting on yourself
or are you being told directly you must
get here an hour early and you're going
to
have to stay an hour later and i ask
that because
i have allowed myself in certain jobs in
certain places to just become
consumed and absorbed by the work i had
this fantasy that there would ever be a
day
when i could just leave my work and
every task would be done
everything my desk would be clear if you
will and
it took me a long time in management and
senior leadership before i realized
that day doesn't exist there will always
be a day when i come in the next morning
when i've got things up
ready to rock and roll that i have a
project i've got to be done i've got you
know
employee issues i've got to deal with
and then i've also been at places
that had unrealistic what i would call
obnoxious expectations of my time
in my life basically we own you so
where where does it fall are you
inventing some of this or is it pretty
clear this is the expectation of your
life
it's kind of a culture but right i mean
um as the workforce continues to
get smaller and smaller there's less
work or there's more work and less
people
so i mean basically it just piles on you
and there's never any catching up unless
you're
actually working the hours to get it
done so okay it's probably a little bit
of both to be honest
okay um so snap your fingers
i i tell you and i'm getting this
question from my good friend ken coleman
who is the work career
expert and i want to recommend when you
get done with me that you look into his
information his book proximity principle
he's working on a new book right now and
you can catch his radio show too
and he walks people through the actual
steps to get a job but
a question he asks often is i guarantee
you can't fail
you're going to submit one application
and you will get the that
other job at that other place paint me a
picture of what that looks like
if you did move if you did leave you're
going to write them a 100 000
check for the cost of your mba and then
you're going to leave
where would you go what would you do
yeah so the check would be about 30 000
at this point so it's not a 100 okay
it's still significant yeah but but it
would likely be in like a non-management
position
uh i've done that for a number of years
and it's kind of just
you know weighed on me so you know
trying to find
something where you can have a lot of
purpose work hard
but also have you know some boundaries
right
um and executives that aren't toxic
and and that that much but so that's
kind of like the about or at least what
i've
wrote in my head so far but i i do have
some work to do yet okay so that feels
really amorphous to me
and like well it could be so it could be
this or i and it sounds like you're
running away from something not to
something and so
my recommendation to you would be to
number one don't jump ship don't run out
the door
until you have a concrete place uh to go
to
where you're headed is it wrong or
um immoral or is it right to be thinking
about
man this company is continuing to
implode on itself it's
dysfunctional they're asking me to do
things that are making me uncomfortable
or they're just
sucking the soul like sucking my soul
from me
um man of course it's good to think
those thoughts of course it's gonna be
planning for the future
i i like folks to especially
who have made it a what i would call an
integrity commitment they invested in
you
and you signed a piece of paper saying
hey i'm here and unless they're asking
you to do something that violates your
moral boundaries
um they are asking you to do something
that is immoral or
challenges your integrity i like the
idea of folks
really doubling down on themselves and
what i mean by that is
taking this as a season that to begin
practicing boundaries
begin practicing here's what i'm going
to allow in my life
and i'm going to create a world that
exists outside of that life
that fits in with the world i've created
instead of letting the outside world
dictate what happens on the inside
and this this involves a a piece of
management that doesn't get talked about
very often and it is this idea of
self-leadership
you've got to lead yourself first and so
have you
michael have you ever sat back and said
here are my priorities
and really detailed those for instance
i will spend two hours a day with my
kids period
i will be home with my wife and kids for
dinner
this many days a week period and
co-create this with your wife co-create
this universe and then
backfill it because here's what happens
a lot people run away from something
they end up in another thing whether
it's a relationship with another kid and
another job
and the the damning thing is you went
with you
the you who didn't have divine places to
go define
goals to go defined relationship
ideas and pictures they go with you too
and so you just show up at another place
and it's amorphous again and it feels
mushy and then it's uncomfortable
because everything's uncomfortable right
now it's a disaster
business is changing underneath us
corporate structures are changing
underneath us
um we owe trillions
of dollars right medicine is changing
education is changing it's all changing
underneath us
and what i want to challenge you on
michael is to not think the solution is
going to be
just over there i want you to really
have a
a bright developed picture of what
that's
there is going to look like and then
work towards that so when i ask you like
have you backed out and said here's what
my home life i want it to look like and
we're going to build a world around that
have you done that
i'll be honest no okay it's not a bad
thing most people haven't man it's not
it's not a judgment thing it's just
something to think through
yeah yeah i honestly think in my company
the people that are most flexible end up
you know rising to the top because
they've been extremely pliable and
flexible
um and so so that that's good advice
though
well and here's the thing that's what
you think on your side of the fence
and i consider myself a really flexible
employee
i was here really early this morning on
a media call with
a radio station in another state and
then i went and came in here i'm doing
this radio show and i'm going to leave
here and do some other things
but i blocked off this afternoon weeks
ago
for a secret get my kid out of school
and we're going to go
have some fun at some local thing this
afternoon
not going to move it not going to change
it
it's been on the books because i have a
certain amount of time i want to spend
with my son each week and last week we
had a lot of speaking engagements a lot
of radio shows a lot of media
and i lost that and so i'm gonna i'm
going to backfill out this week
but what that's about is highly highly
intentional
and so what i want to encourage you
michael is a get with my friend ken
coleman
kingcoleman.com you can go and see all
of his stuff on
how to think through changing jobs how
to think through the money part of it
you can call his show but i also this is
bigger than that
i want you to get with your wife and i
want you guys to sit down and say what
is our life gonna look like
what do we want it to look like and
i want you to be okay with what that
means
what am i saying i'm saying sometimes
people want a million dollars
and they want a salary i want to make a
million dollars
and i want to never miss a little league
game ever
i want to be at home six nights a week
for dinner and
often those two things are not
compatible they don't work
but p and so people end up living lives
with this low level
depression this low level anxiety this
constant frustration
because they haven't said here's what i
want and here's what it's going to cost
and be okay with either way it may be
that you say i miss my family and your
wife says
i miss you here and you say i'm gonna
leave management i'm gonna go be
a more front-line employee we're all
agreeing as
a home that we're gonna make less money
for this season which means we're going
to have a little bit of a smaller house
we're going to have to all share a
bathroom
and we're all going to know that going
in and then when people know
golly man they can overcome they can
deal with they can manage and they can
make the best of
situations it's when they are living
into this expectation that's not real
that's not real that's not real it's
different i'm uncomfortable
and then we just start looking around
and blaming so michael start from the
top
get with your wife what do we want our
home to look like what do we want our
relationships to look by
like and then draw some firm boundaries
begin to practice self-leadership
and i'd say stay in your job and begin
to manage your boundaries
make a boss call you in and say
you have to be here two hours before and
that may mean that you have to change
your one-on-one cycle with your
employees that may mean that you do a
lot more stuff electronically
than you used to that may mean that
you're going to change some of these
things
but you're going to change your
management style to match how you want
your life to be not the other way around
awesome question michael thank you so
much
um let's go to danny in fort worth texas
danny what's up my man
hey john how you doing outstanding how
are you i'm great thanks for taking some
time to talk to me this is uh
this is awesome so i listen to you guys
all the time thank you very much well
thank you it's awesome for me too how
can i help this morning
yeah i want to try and be brief so i'm
summarizing a year's worth of history
and a lot of stuff that has
uh i've had bottled up over the last
year but uh the straw that broke the
camel's back this most
recent weekend as my dad completely
disrespected my wife
in our home um
and that's a tough one for me and for a
multitude of reasons but at the end of
the day i have to pick my wife
so um hey can we stop there can we stop
there for a second
sure good for you my man thank you hey
listen
i'm being serious and i'm looking
directly in this camera and i know
you're listening to me right now you
can't see me
good for you that's the right decision
we're supposed to respect our parents
but people do not respect
disrespect our spouses in our homes good
for you
okay continue all right so over the last
year we have
uh i'm one of four children okay
three of my siblings all have kids as
well
my three boys my wife and i felt are not
treated with the same
uh priority as the rest of the kids okay
they were grandkids i should say
so i've had our parents over my parents
over twice in the last year to directly
confront them about it and and gave them
plenty of warnings that hey we'd like to
have you guys over to our home to talk
about these things we've done that twice
okay uh both times no there was no real
animosity no issues nothing was going on
from my parents as far as we could tell
everything seemed to be fine
and then this last weekend oh i should
back up a little bit they they even went
about two or three weeks ago and said it
just completely surprised us
showed up at our house at about 8 30 in
the on a sunday morning with donuts for
all the grandkids
it was a huge huge effort phenomenal
it's great for us
so we thought okay water's under the
bridge everything's fine
and then my uh my youngest son turned
one
just we had his big big birthday i
thought it was a college graduation with
how much my wife played
into it um but it was great
my dad comes in doesn't say that i say
hi to him and stuff like that he doesn't
say a word to my wife
the entire time we're there deliberately
uh walks avoids her doesn't won't talk
to her
um she starts to notice it more and more
throughout the day it says hey did i do
something to upset your dad ask me a
couple questions so i start looking at
it listen
kind of being like well you know maybe
she's just overreacting or missing
something or maybe he's off or something
like that so i tried to look at it and
uh sure enough he'd write him and i
intently watched
multiple potential interactions where
she uh
avoided her to the point of
you know they'd pass by each other and
he'd intentionally look the opposite
direction things like that
yeah um so then i let the party go on
uh everything's fine next day there's
some other issues with my siblings that
we were that i was also addressing
but uh not to get into that here i set
up i opened up a group text
to my dad my mom and my siblings i said
hey guys there's some issues i wanted to
talk to you guys individually about
but um my wife felt extremely
disrespected
in our house and i don't i don't
appreciate that
and i specifically called my dad out in
that i said dad i would expect
i'm i'm frustrated to see
your leadership in our family
and think that it's okay to treat my
wife with disrespect because i know it
wouldn't be okay for me to treat
your wife with disrespect in your home
um
and kyle called some of the specific
stuff out well so he responded to me
and it's basically his well his exact
response was
um i was not once acknowledged all night
long
even with a hello until i said goodbye
keep dumping on us
and place blame on us where we are okay
with that
some things need to be figured out and
we will not be the ones to point it out
i will not respond
yep um so again i didn't want to do it
all through text message i
in my message i said i would like to
address these things individually
one-on-one
sure but these are this is kind of where
i'm at what his text message to me
said is that yes we do have issues
even though you've come over twice and
told us no we don't and
she started it so i'm not going to
respond or something to that effect
right
she started it she disrespected me first
so it's okay for me to disrespect her
on top of that his response sets a
precedence
in front of my siblings that it's okay
to treat my wife that way
and so and so let me make sure i'm clear
here when you say disrespected my wife
he didn't call her names he didn't laugh
in her face
he he essentially ignored her during an
event at your home
is that right yes and so then i asked
him
why and and in his response he's
he's directly saying well she did it to
me first
well that's how i interpret she didn't
acknowledge me once so
i didn't acknowledge her and i'm just
going to completely but there's
there's there's history there already
sure where stuff like this has happened
before
so and that's his way of of of um
pouting i don't know how to put it yeah
maybe that's a little rough
no dude men pout all the time i i've
done that before
um that's that's a way that that men can
non and non-abusively take power over a
room
is by hovering with their pouting right
that's a powerful
dude move um so
let me challenge you on some things
before we dig into your old man okay
yep who has made you the the home
quarterback or i would call the the
moral
character quarterback of your house it
seems like you are
on prowl for
like you're gonna make sure you talk to
your brothers and sisters about things
you're gonna talk to your mom and dad
about things you're gonna have these
talks
who anointed you and that's that's a
loaded word i know who anointed you
the character and morality police of
your family unit
yeah that's a really good question i
don't i don't think anybody
has that necessarily or has given me
that i think maybe i
appointed myself okay okay um i don't
not that i
intentionally meant to when you put it
that way but yeah so
the second thing is is you mention this
but i just got to say dude
the worst thing you can possibly do ever
is to address your entire
family on issues of
character frustration about your wife
via text message right because everybody
hears those things differently and
as you're telling the story i understand
there's years of history that i'm not
privy to
but i wonder if my son and his wife
called me over and said
the way you're treating your grandkids
isn't right
it's not fair here's five reasons why
you're treating them differently than
you're treating
my brothers and sisters kids and then
nothing changes
and then i get another lecture from my
son about how i'm not grandparenting
in a way that he sees fit and then i
try i reach out and i bring donuts i'm
trying now now i'm going over
i'm i'm going okay we're going to be
hyper intentional about this
nothing says i love you like a box of
carbs and sugar right
especially for kids and then i
show up i'm on high alert i want to be
present
i don't want to speak when with in say
wrong things i don't want to
look the wrong ways i want to be fully
in
and then i walk in and i just happen to
walk past
my daughter-in-law and she's busy and
she doesn't acknowledge me
and so i my initial thought is oh did i
do something wrong again
i'm on the defensive now because they've
already called me over their house and
lectured me twice
these kids that are half my age and half
my wisdom have lectured me twice
i don't know what to do with this deal
and so i'm going to pass her a few times
and make sure she sees me make sure she
knows i'm here
and she ignores me twice well now i'm
going to be i'm get
my inner child is going to come out i'm
going to act like a baby and if you're
going to ignore me then i'm going to
ignore you
right but i'm just wondering if
these are grown-ups acting like children
in this
environment everyone's going to point a
finger at each other
you're the guy that keeps calling folks
over to lecture them on how they need to
be better brothers and sisters and
parents and grandparents
that just sounds like a lot of heat man
and i'm wondering if there's a way that
nobody can win in this deal
unless they do it exactly like danny
wants it done
for our kids for my wife i don't see it
as a
like as if your brothers and sisters
know your dad is a powder
and he acts like a baby i don't see that
as
a free license to now they can
disrespect
your wife i don't see it that way at all
if your brothers and sisters know that
about your old man they know that about
your old man right and if they know
you're the lecturer then they know that
about you too
um and even if i have a license to
disrespect somebody's wife who i love
i'm not going to because i'm a person of
character right and hopefully they're
that same way too
but it sounds like you are on high high
offense alert
where does that come from yeah so
um like the justice police like you're
ready yeah no you're to fight you're
right you're absolutely right and i
didn't and it's great perspective
and i definitely haven't thought of it
that way where does that come from
though because it comes from probably a
good place that your sense of justice
comes from a good place
where where is that from i think it's
from a long history of
i was expected to
growing up i mean i was not allowed to
make mistakes i wasn't allowed to not
say hi to somebody when you walked in
their house i wasn't allowed to
i mean i know i mean to the point where
we uh
in significant trouble whatever that
looked like right grounded or
sure publicly and you know whatever uh
so and then that
um the i'll say that the
how do i word this the uh parenting
style
my parents have changed significantly
from my older sister and i
to my younger brother and sister who is
specifically
the two that i'm addressing here so
maybe it's this feeling of
um and this this is a horrible
way of wording it but maybe it's a
feeling of moral superiority
which is not true yep um it feels like a
uh like a fraternity we had to do it so
you have to do it
and you all didn't have it you all
didn't have it as hard as we had it and
so you're never
really going to be true brothers because
we got branded and hit in the face with
bricks and y'all just got to right right
that kind of thing
yep yeah um so so that's that's part of
it now the other piece of it uh
is probably some emotional response on
my part because my wife
uh tries so hard to include everybody
sure and
and to bring everybody over there and
it's affecting
she's starting to wonder what am i doing
wrong and we've
we have had them over twice and we have
asked them and they keep saying nothing
and then my dad's response
kind of sounded like well there is
something wrong but we're not going to
point it out sure
and i was like well thanks for your help
i guess like i mean um or
for not helping and so it was affecting
the way my wife felt about herself
and the way she um
she she's crying to me and saying why am
i
not good enough for your family kind of
thing there you go right and
for the and for the last year i've been
telling her
a year and a half hey if we'll just make
the effort here i know my family they
will respond
and you'll be welcomed with open arms
and love and kindness and it just hasn't
been the case there you go
and so there's probably some frustration
there for me as well and i want to tell
you i want to affirm that frustration
if anybody's mean or disrespectful to my
wife if they ignore my wife if they're
ugly to her
man my defenses go up my emotions go up
my desire to seek justice on her behalf
goes up
that makes you somebody who cares about
your wife right so here's
here's a perspective i want to give to
you
okay number one
stop being the justice morality police
for the people who love you and people
who are around you
it's exhausting for them and more
importantly it's exhausting for you
yep and you are wearing yourself out
psychologically spiritually emotionally
and you're wearing out the most
important deepest threaded relationships
in your life
honestly for not a lot of reason and
here i'm going to tell you why
that leads me to number two you've got
to take your family members
out of your box and i've got a youtube
rant on this but at the end of the day
you should have four or five people in
your life
that you allow to hurt your feelings
that you allow
you choose who hurts your feelings you
choose who quote unquote gets a
vote into your life you love your wife
and you love your kids and you think
they are awesome and they probably are
they might not be but they probably are
right right right
at the end of the day other people don't
have to see it that way
and if you choose to set off every time
somebody doesn't see it that way
you're just going to scorch earth around
you you're going to end up with a pile
of bodies yours included and that's a
waste of that's a waste of a joyful life
and so i would take my dad out of the
box you've sat him down and talked to
him
right you have talked to your mom and
said here's how we want we would like
y'all to show appreciation for our
children
and they are communicating through their
actions no
and you can continue to go to war with
that or you can say
great that's how they choose to live the
people i want in my
life are going to honor my kids and my
wife in a certain way
so i'm taking my parents out out of that
box am i going to be mature and respect
them
of course am i going to invite them to
birthday parties yup
and i'm also going to tell my wife and
we're going to have this conversation
with her
they don't have permission to hurt your
feelings anymore there's
nothing you can do to make them be
different they are who they are
your dad's probably been had bouts of
immaturity through your entire childhood
and then he probably tried to
overcorrect with your younger two
siblings
and be the cool dad who just let stuff
was cool and cool and cool
and that he probably found different
connection with them and he did with you
guys and probably treat your kids
differently as a result
it is what it is what it is what you are
what you are choosing to do is let your
character be defined by somebody else's
actions
no that's good you are responsible for
your character
you are responsible for modeling what a
dad looks like to your
your young kids okay and so
i want you to own
your heart your home and that's it and
if your brothers and sisters are jerks
to you then they're not invited
they're just not and that's not any skin
off your back that's not any skin enough
it's not a testament to your wife's
role as how good of a job she's doing it
just is
and all of us have people in our
families that come to birthday parties
and act differently than we probably
wish they would
and we can choose to invite them or not
and then we're going to just know what
we're getting right we're just going to
know what we're getting we're going to
move on i'm not going to spend the
emotional and physical energy trying to
change other people and
that man i'm telling you right now you
are setting yourself up for a life
of lightness a lot a life of joy
in my family my wife actually sends an
email to my family
and they will say here's when we're
going to be in town here's what i want
to do for dinner here's what i want to
do after dinner
we're bringing games we're going to go
for walks the guys are going to go out
into the woods
whatever is happening and she sets an
agenda and it's awesome the whole film
is like okay sweet cool
and right we will say we are not going
to talk about politics this year that's
going to be a
a family deal and my family knows i will
get up and walk out the door
and i love them but i'm not going to
subject myself
and my family and my love my beloved
relationships to fights
especially when we only get to see each
other a few times a year i'm not gonna
do it and so we're not gonna talk about
politics we're gonna talk about other
things we've got plenty of other stuff
to talk about
and so it's just setting those
boundaries in yourself and being okay
with it talking to your wife and letting
her know that she is not
on probationary status here she is not
at a tryout
she is loving her kids the best way she
knows how she's loving you the best way
she knows how
and some people just aren't gonna like
that and that is their problem
not y'alls is that fair do you get what
i'm saying no
no i totally get what you're saying um
so i see a counselor on my own yeah she
always helps me
um talks me off the ledge so to speak
like you are here
okay where
um our emotions cloud our reason our
logic
and so um no this has been phenomenal uh
i really appreciate it
question is this gonna be on the podcast
here shortly yeah yeah yeah
it'll be launched sometime yeah um yeah
do me a favor
the next time your dad does something or
your mom does something or your brothers
and sisters do something
and it immediately sets your feelings
off it immediately sets your emotions
off
before you say anything write them down
and then i want you to look at the
feelings you've written down
and demand evidence from them so for
instance
i got you your wife is gonna pull you
aside and say dad's
ignoring me he is completely
disrespecting me and you're gonna see it
happen
and you're gonna write down you're gonna
get you're gonna get instantly pissed
off and you're gonna write it down
dad's ignoring my wife which leads to
dads disrespecting my wife which is
gonna lead to
dad and you're gonna fill in the blank
on what's wrong with that
and at that moment i want you to get out
of your dad's head because you don't
know what's going on in there
he might be trying to tiptoe his way
through a party
to honor you honor her and he's just
doing a crappy job at it
and he might be trying to just be a
complete jerk and act like a
two-year-old and he might have 50 other
things going on he might
be not feeling good and trying right and
so
after this call i want you to not text
not electronically communicate i want
you to call your brothers and sisters
who are on that text
and say look y'all are grown-ups i'm a
grown-up i should not have texted you
guys i'm sorry
i am not your parents i'm not your moral
police
i'm just trying to get everybody to love
each other and i screwed this up and i'm
sorry
and i want you to not explain just let
that be and they may say yeah that's
right
you suck take it just take it i'm sorry
you're right
and i want you to call your old man i
want you to call your old man and say
dude
i don't know what got into me i'm your
son
i don't have any business lecturing you
guys i know you love our grandkids i
know you love me i know you love your
wife
i was out of line i'm sorry and then let
it
go and if your dad wants to talk to you
after that which he might he might not
cool
let it go just like frozen one
and not frozen too not holding back
anymore let it go
let it go right um but call him and
apologize call your mom and say dude i
don't know what i was in
in my head i'm your son i'm lecturing my
parents that's not cool
i'm out i'm not doing that anymore y'all
are doing the best you can i appreciate
you
and then you and your wife get in a room
and decide
what are we going to get our feelings
heard over and what are we not going to
get our feelings heard over who are
going to let hurt our feelings and who
are not going to let our feelings
let hurt our feelings and then move on
then let it go
all right danny you are uh i'm so
grateful for the call
appreciate your heart appreciate you
being a guy who's trying to get it right
trying to care about people
but is also trying to wrestle hard with
his feelings and emotions you're a good
man
and i appreciate you call me back after
you call your family and apologize i
want to hear how those go
we'll have you back on the show i want
to hear how that goes can't wait all
right let's go to take one more call
let's go to jackie in los angeles
jackie what's up dr g how are you today
i'm so good how are you good thank you
thanks so much for taking
my call you betcha what can i do to help
um
yeah so today i'm having troubles
connecting with my sister-in-law
and i was hoping maybe you can help me
try to understand
why this is and maybe ways to fix it
okay
tell me how you're having trouble just
uh having trouble connecting
yeah so you know a little back story um
she met my brother-in-law and i think
their relationship moved very quickly
um you know they met they got um married
they're expecting a baby all like within
a year or less
okay and so i feel like i didn't get a
chance to really
get to know her i only met her a couple
times and then all the serious stuff
happened so i feel like you know we're
cordial enough
but a lot of times i feel like um i'm
kind of carrying like the conversations
on my back like
i'll ask her a question you know like
what's your favorite food and it'll just
be like oh italian and then the
conversation kind of ends
and so i just feel like i would love a
better relationship where
i mean in an ideal world maybe more of
like a friendship you know what i mean
just because
you know we see each other somewhat
often so um
and also just to get you know um again
just
to have a better relationship i think
that we just it's kind of awkward and
sure and again i don't know i'm just
trying to figure out like if it's coming
from me like am i
like deep down for some reason like i
don't know jealous or like you know it's
a sister-in-law
thing where it's like you know we're
both you know
i don't know not competition necessarily
but just trying to figure out
how i can maybe connect with her better
do you miss your brother
yeah you know i do but also another
thing is that i
i see them and again i know it's none of
my business it's not my relationship
but she's she's snapped on him a few
times in front of me
and i just feel like again i i don't
intervene
i'm kind of just like this is not my
business but i don't appreciate that
sure you know what i mean yeah totally
but i think but it's probably part of it
good for you yeah so you're defensive of
your brother you love him you miss him
you are right to not get in the middle
that's his wife and that's their
relationship dynamic however
weird it is for you right until she
becomes abusive which of course then
you're gonna get involved
um but yeah you're gonna have you're
gonna have your snap judgments
here's what you need to do and it's
simple jackie and it's directed to the
point
i want you to reach out to her do you
all live in the same community the same
area can you all get together in person
yeah okay i want you to invite her to
coffee
are you even allowed to do that in los
angeles i don't know how that works um
you know we can have out we can order it
and then take it out to a park
okay so i want you to i want you to take
her out
i want you to pay and i want you to tell
her
you are a part of my family i am i
consider you a sister now
and i want to develop a great
relationship with you
this is super weird because we're both
grown-ups and so i'm being vulnerable
here
i want to have a great relationship with
you and i want to grow
and develop a friendship with you how do
we start
and i want you to be that vulnerable
with her because here's the deal
you're going to peter along for the next
decade
dropping a little hint here what do you
think about this here
and then on the other side of that scale
you're going to see her nitpick your
brother you're going to see her make fun
of him when he puts on some weight
you're going to
see her treat your nieces and nephews
differently than you would treat them
and that scale is going to get out of
whack and what you are gonna avoid this
whole time is being vulnerable with her
and it's gonna end in an explosion and
then your poor brother's gonna have to
choose between his sister and his wife
you can cut all that crap out by just
taking her out on the front end of this
deal
and saying you're in my family now
you are my sister i want to grow to get
to know you
and i'm being super vulnerable and this
is weird for both of us i'm making it
awkward and i'm sorry
but i want to grow to love you i want to
grow to be connected with you
i want you to start coming over and
hanging out at the house i want to know
what you
love what you don't love and let's just
get weird
right nick miller style let's just get
weird and let's develop a grown-up
relationship we don't know how to do
this we don't have any
skills for how to make grown-up adult
friendships that's why we're all lonely
as old people after we get out of
college we just have like one or two
people at work and then we just get
lonely right so you are going out on a
limb
and you got to be ready for this her
looking at you saying
oh sure that'd be great and then never
calling you again
you've got to be ready for your brother
to be like what is the matter with you
did you seriously take my wife to a park
and ask her quote to be your friend
that's what serial killers do you weirdo
right you have to be ready
because relationship is about risk but
what you're doing is you're
short-circuiting a decade of uncertainty
a decade of judgment and back and forth
and poking and prodding all that
you're just going to go for it you're
going to risk you're going to be
vulnerable
you're going to say i want to be your
friend you're my sister i love you let's
do this
and then you're going to let her respond
my gut is my hope is that she's going to
go oh thank god i didn't know how to do
this i know he talks so highly about you
his sister he loves
i feel like i'm always competing with
you and that sounds weird like flowers
in the attic because i know you and your
brother
aren't like like that but you all have a
great relationship and i feel all weird
in the middle of it
and she's gonna be relieved ah thank god
so good for you for wanting to connect
your family deeper
go for it jackie go for it and then i
want you to call me back and let me know
how that conversation went
and you may call back and be like
deloney you suck you idiot i was
vulnerable
and i ruined everything good for you now
you know
you get you get a decade of your life
back right and i didn't even charge you
for it
that was free advice right jackie so
thank you so much for the call
as we wrap up today's show this morning
during a media hit um the engineer
and i don't know if you guys know um
engineers but they generally
have souls made of wires and zeros and
ones that's kind of how they that's how
they become engineers i guess
but they are often lovely lovely
wonderful people especially the
engineers we have here the sound
engineers here are like some of the most
great guys ever
well this morning as you're getting
ready for the media hit one of them
started blasting
old school bell biv devoe which if you
don't know
number one turn the podcast off go
straight to spotify and start listening
to bell biv devote the whole record
awesome stuff but it got me thinking
that was a great
awesome 90s hip-hop group
but the kings the kings of 90s hip-hop
which of course as we all know is the
greatest music of all time
except for a few right is
a group that actually talks about
puberty in the name of their band
from this to this and in 1991 they
dropped their debut album
they have a band that describes puberty
in the name
they dropped their debut album about
their hometown
i'm talking about boys to men and their
first single from their 1991 debut
motown philly
they didn't even bother to change the
name of the song that's how good it was
the song was so good they're like you
know what forget it let's just name the
whole record this
and everyone in the room went that's
right motown philly
boys to men their number one single from
their 1991 debut
here's what they say they say motown
philly's back
again doing a little east coast swing
boys to men going off not too hard but
not too soft it's long overdue but
philly is slamming
boys to men abc bbd the east coast
family
never skipping a beat now while cooling
on south street
back in school we used to dream about
this every day could it really happen
or do dreams just fade away then we
started singing them
then it sounded smooth and we started a
group and here we are kicking it for who
just for you that's right boys to men
motown philly kicking it just for you
this
is the dr john deloney show
you